we're continuing our conversation today
with Pete simi who is a professor of
sociology at Chapman University the book
as we've mentioned which he co-authored
with Robert Bottrell is American
swastika inside the white power
movements hidden spaces of hate let's
talk a little bit about the current
political climate we've seen based on
SPLC
reporting anti-defamation league FBI
that a lot of the types of neo-nazi
white supremacists anti-semitic
extremism that you research is more in
the forefront today but my question is
whether the rhetoric of Donald Trump
these sort of signals that we've seen
sent to white supremacists and white
nationalists does that actually create
more of this ideology or does it merely
make people more willing to publicly
express their beliefs yeah I think it's
more of the latter this is uh in some
ways this is a really unique time in
that white supremacists feel that they
have this special relationship in some
cases with with President Trump where
you know we're literally white
supremacists talk about you know the
signals as you mentioned that they feel
like he's sending to them and so you
know that's something we haven't seen
with past at least in recent history
with past you know presidential
administrations where white supremacists
feel this kind of kinship almost to to
the to the White House at the same time
we need to be clear that these groups
have been around and have been kind of
biding their time and and really you
know from on there and working hard to
kind of remain vital
remain active you know they've been
using social media since the you know
the first days of the internet they were
though they were on the Internet they
were on electronic bulletin boards
before you know the internet really was
created you know they've been using you
know social media for years to kind of
spread their messages and and distribute
their propaganda
recruit and so forth they've cultivated
an underground music scene that for
years has been important in terms of
influencing people and helping recruit
people and giving people kind of these
places to come together to share with
like-minded others you know they use the
family as a resource as a place of
infrastructure to kind of build that
their their movements so you know these
groups have been doing things kind of
more under the radar to really keep
themselves going and now there's this
political moment that's emerged where
they feel like they have an opportunity
to really kind of exert themselves and
be more open and really kind of flaunt
themselves and so now we're seeing the
kind of this come to fruition
unfortunately in this time where things
are so polarized this gives these types
of groups a lot of oxygen where they can
feel like they can use the the tensions
the conflicts that exist within society
to their advantage and they can make a
lot of hay out of it can you talk a
little bit about specifically what sort
of signals these individuals see coming
from Trump because when I when I spoke
to white nationalist leader Richard
Spencer and said to him you know it's
interesting that Donald Trump does have
a Jewish son-in-law his grandchildren or
Jewish he has you know as a New Yorker
he does business with with all sorts of
different people in New York immigrants
Jews non-whites etc but yet there are
signals that he has sent either
willingly or unwillingly consciously or
subconsciously what specifically is it
that though that a white nationalist
seasoned Trump that makes them say
that's the guy or at least that's the
closest to our guy that we've had right
well you know if we go pre
the the presidential campaign and look
at his role in the birther movement that
that was really a big signal before
before the the you know a presidential
race so right off the bat he enters the
campaign with a certain degree of
stature among white supremacists because
of his willingness to really tout this
conspiracy theory these lies about
President Obama who you know of course
you know the idea of electing
african-american president for white
supremacist is is a real nightmare of
sorts so that that that period of time
running up to you know the eight years
prior to 2016 we saw really galvanized
white supremacist before before Trump's
election because of our first
african-american president
so Trump comes into the campaign already
with that on his resume so to speak and
then on the first day he comes down the
escalator and talks about Mexicans being
rapists and so forth that was a huge
signal right off the bat that this is
something different
does this person it may be doing
something a little bit differently in
terms of politics as usual business as
usual and that got their ears open at
least to say well wait a second let's
see what else this guy has to say and
then when you look at what he did during
the campaign retweeting white
supremacists dozens of times using
faulty fake propaganda about crime rates
in terms of african-americans targeting
whites
you know these various different kinds
of things during the campaign you know
kind of you know really sent these kind
of messages to to white supremacist that
this is a different kind of politician
he might be you know willing to express
things about kind of white grievances in
a way that they hadn't seen before and
then since he's been in the White House
when you use words like [ __ ]
countries for example that term is
literally the language of white
supremacy these are the kinds of ways
they describe you know countries uh you
know what they would call non-white
countries they would call them mud holes
they would call them cesspools so when
he said [ __ ] countries I mean he's
literally speaking their language and so
it's these kind of signals you know he
talks about an infestation in terms of
immigration these are the kinds of words
that really are meaningful to these
groups because they dehumanize different
countries different groups in a way that
is very very comparable to what these
groups do and so that really resonates
with these folks do we have any reason
to think one way or the other that this
kind of coalescing and catalyzing of the
these ideologies will last only as long
as Trump is in the White House or will
his presence in the White House for four
or eight or some intermediate number
depending on what you think will happen
legally will that persist beyond his
presidency
unfortunately I I would say you know
persists beyond this is and you know we
need to be careful with the in terms of
electoral politics the problem is far
bigger than Donald Trump
so you know we have just re-elected a
congressman in Iowa who openly is
touting white supremacist propaganda
about white genocide of this so-called
replacement theory the idea that other
racial groups are replacing White's
which is literally a different term for
the idea of white genocide which these
groups have have been touting obviously
for a long time so for people who don't
know just about your I think you're
referring to Steve King who of course
narrowly defeated our friend JD Scholten
who put up a great great campaign but
unfortunately fell short all right right
exactly and so you know it when you have
politicians who are peddling in these
kinds of fears and anxieties and are
having some success with it
it does speak to the problem being much
bigger than just one person I mean
obviously Trump's kind of the spearhead
of this but but it's a bigger problem
and so I definitely see it persisting
whether whether we're talking beyond you
know 2020 or we're talking about 2024
you know this is something I think we
have you know the problem preceded Trump
and so you know the idea that it's not
going to persist Trump is is somewhat
naive dand this is something I think we
have to do a better job of coming to
terms with and thinking about how
pervasive this problem actually is and
not kind of minimizing it or denying it
which is I think unfortunately what
we've tended to do with this issue can
you talk a little bit about at the world
level so we have we've talked about
what's going on in the United States
with Trump we've also seen the rise of
some pretty extreme nationalist parties
in Europe we've seen this in Poland
Germany Hungary there's a lot of
different places we can point to
from a sort of empirical perspective or
point of view is there any way to
measure at the worldwide level the
degree to which these ideologies exist
over time or is that something that's
difficult academically to study yeah I
mean it is you know quite difficult um
you know we definitely you know
electoral politics helps because you
know you can kind of use that as a proxy
measure but a lot of these groups you
know are kind of working under the radar
they have a presence on social media to
a large extent but that that gets you
know complicated in terms of measuring
exactly what that that presence on
social media translates to in terms of
like say sheer numbers sheer volume of
people involved you can look at public
protests and turnout at you know
protests in some cases in Europe in
particular some of the public protests
among far-right extremists they've
they've literally had hundreds of
thousands turnout in some events so you
know you see those kinds of numbers and
you get a sense of the scale but coming
up with more precise measures is is
quite difficult last thing I want to
touch on to circle back to part one of
the conversation when people do leave
these ideologies be it for ideological
reasons or as we talked about sometimes
more practical problems that it's
causing them problems in relationships
problems in society with work is it
typically a clean break or is there a
sort of relapse that tends to happen so
we find that with a segment of our folks
that there's definitely there's actual
relapse literally where people will
leave and then go back and then even
more common even for folks who don't
necessarily leave and then go back the
struggle can be quite substantial in
terms of after they leave and and kind
of reintegrating into society can be
very difficult there's often a lot of
obstacles in some cases people you know
have gotten tattoos all over their
bodies and so literally there's these
visible markers that kind of set them
off and set them apart and in in other
cases they're it's more invisible the
obstacles and there's a lot of kind of
psychological work that needs to be done
by individuals and you know really
receiving the appropriate kinds of
support to work through a some of the
problems that you know really preceded
their involvement some unresolved trauma
oftentimes from childhood whether it be
physical or sexual abuse or other types
of kind of environmental adversities
that really destabilize their lives
early on and and have gone unresolved so
kind of getting at some of those root
issues but then also once a person gets
involved in these groups then they often
will encounter and be part of you know
some pretty traumatic experiences in
terms of violence witnessing violence
are actually you know engaging in
violence themselves and so you know
really a person will often have to work
through a lot of kind of turmoil and
baggage after they leave the group and
it's not often a you know a clean break
and you know we do we do see that from
time to time people report that you know
they just kind of one day decided to
leave and then that was it but that's
pretty uncommon it's it's usually more
kind of a struggle after personal ease
the book is excellent it's called
American swastika inside the white power
movements hidden spaces of hate
co-written with Robert Ferrell we've
been speaking with Pete simi who is
professor of sociology at Chapman
University thanks so much for talking to
me about all this
no thanks for having me I appreciate it